قال مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي في بيان
انه يشعر بقلق بالغ ازاء التقارير التي
تحدثت عن قصف منشاه تابعه للانرويد حيث
افادت التقارير باحت ماء اكثر من 30 الف
نازحا فيه اضاف البيان ان على اسرائيل
مسؤوليه حمايه المدنيين بما في ذلك
العاملون في المجال الانساني ومواقع تقديم
خدمات انسانيه اضاف المجلس في بيانه انه
من المفجع رؤيه اطفال يقتلون ويصاب واكد
دعم ما وصفه حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن
نفسها بما يتماشى مع القانون الانساني
الدولي ضد
حماس من جهتها قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الهجوم على مركز تدريب تابع
للامم المتحده في خانيونس مثير للقلق بشكل
لا يصدق وجدد نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه فيدانت باتيل الدعوه لحمايه
المدنيين وموظفي الاغاثه والمنشات التابعه
للمنظمات
الانسانيه مثير للقلق بشكل لا يصدق ناسف
للهجوم الذي وقع اليوم على مركز التدريب
التابع للامم المتحده في خان يونس يجب
حمايه المدنيين ويجب احترام الطبيعه
المحميه لمرافق الامم المتحده ويجب حمايه
العاملين في المجال الانساني حتى يتمكنوا
من الاستمرار في تقديم الم العالات
الانسانيه المنقذ للحياه التي يحتاج اليها
المدنيون